it's been a really great 2017 for our
long-form investigative pieces these
date all the way back to the beginning
of 2016 with the first long-form piece
called reza aslan cannot be trusted and
that's one that did very very well and
during 2017 we did a number of
additional long-form pieces if you're
looking for them there's actually a
playlist on our YouTube channel if you
go to youtube.com slash the david pakman
show you will see one a playlist called
deep dives and you'll see the full list
including the infamous reza aslan one
and we have some really really good
long-form pieces planned for 2018 the
critical thinking miniseries is in
production and that one will start going
live once we reach 2250 patrons at
patreon.com slash david pakman show some
other possibilities are how white
nationalism gets normalized a long-form
piece into universal healthcare the war
on drugs is a subject that a lot of our
audience wants us to do a deep dive on a
Godwin's law video sort of like when
could we actually say that something is
like the Nazis or like Hitler a lot of
requests for cryptocurrency related
explainers including where does the
value come from what are the tax
implications of cryptocurrency and
Bitcoin type Holdings and what I want to
say to you is if you have any
suggestions for long form pieces you
want us to do just let us know you can
leave a comment on this video email in
at david pakman.com send me a tweet i'm
on twitter at d Pakman send a package
with vegan cheese to the studio and a
little note saying hey Pat make sure
that David covers this long-form piece
and here's some vegan cheese for you
smoke signals telegrams whatever right
just let us know what subjects you're
interested in and we will look into
doing long form investigations many more
to come in 2018